so Lopez spent three months on a
dangerous Journey getting from his
native Venezuela to the United States
he shows me a video he took on his cell
phone while riding on the top of a train
in Mexico heading north
he almost fell off but he took the risk
to get to America to earn money for his
family back home his mom and dad and
three-year-old son
I want to be able to move forward in
life and be able to help my family back
in Venezuela it's very bad there
Lopez arrived in New York three days ago
he is one of thousands of migrants who
have been bussed to the city from Texas
with Promises of work and shelter but
for these men there are neither
a hotel that closed during the pandemic
has been converted into the main
processing center for newly arrived
migrants but it's full all one thousand
rooms taken by women and children so the
men can only sit outside and wait hoping
a spot opens up police have put up
barricades keeping the migrants on the
sidewalk there's not even a toilet many
of these migrants are also from Africa
many are from Angola Chad Senegal and
Sudan they're here with anything that
they have all their belongings after
their long journey to get here to New
York many of them tell us that they
weren't expecting the conditions to be
like this many of the people here are
scared of talking because they just
don't know what to expect next
New York City's migrant shelter system
isn't working the city's mayor Eric
Adams has admitted as much we need help
and it's it's not going to get any
better from from this moment on is
downhill
there is no more room as for Saul this
is not the so-called American Dream he
was expecting
no I didn't expect it to be like this I
came for an opportunity in life and all
I want is to work and have a place to
sleep at night
he went back to the sidewalk behind the
barricades propping himself up on a
trash can this will be where he and many
other like him rest for yet another
night victims of a broken immigration
system
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York